this is Jimmy darts this is for you 500
bucks here's a thousand dollars for you
if either of you give me five dollars
you can have whatever's under his cowboy
hat you're gonna do it all right show
them what he's got you'll want 500 bucks
he's accumulated 12 million followers in
the last two years by surprising
strangers with large amounts of money
ranging from a hundred dollars to a
hundred thousand dollars and he
continues to up the ante having recently
collaborated with Mr Beast by giving
away even more money would you rather
have a thousand dollars in cash right
now or give ten thousand dollars to
someone random in the store oh my God I
won't agree with myself well there you
go today we'll break down the genius
business behind one of the fastest
growing creators on Tick Tock how he's
able to give away so much money where it
all comes from and why it's always a
good idea to buy the mystery box on this
episode of I finally went to the gym
proud of you thanks and of course if you
enjoy episodes like this make sure to
subscribe hit the like button for the
YouTube algorithm comment down below
because we read pretty much all of them
and now with that said we gotta thank
our sponsor and then we'll start the
video but first we gotta thank our
sponsor ftxus some of you have seen
they've been one of the biggest
supporters of our Channel and we really
owe so much of what we have to them
there one of the largest US regulated
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world
with millions of users who buy sell
track and trade both crypto and nfts all
in one place with fees that are up to 85
percent lower than top competitors and
yeah we know crypto has been down
recently but that could pose as a very
interesting opportunity to buy and FTX
is an amazing place to do so they also
allow you to do an automatic recurring
deposit so that you could dollar cost
average to the markets on a regular
basis all you got to do Jack by the way
is just type in what you want how much
you want to buy how often you want to
buy it and then swipe right and you're
done and they're giving you some free
crypto too right all the way up to a
hundred dollars also guys they're soon
launching FTX stocks so you'll be able
to trade stocks crypto and nfts all in
the same place within the same app it's
gonna be amazing definitely check them
out with that link Down Below in the
description and like we mentioned
they've been a huge help for us on the
channel and if we could give them
anything back it would mean a lot to us
if you use the link Down Below in the
description sign up get some free crypto
you may as well would help us out a ton
thank you so much and now back to the
podcast my name is Jimmy darts and so
far the podcast is made 278
000 34 cents let's let's see that that's
actually pretty incredible guess whoa
really yeah it's yeah just off the cuff
do you did you watch any of this uh I
saw a episode probably from I don't know
two three weeks ago or something like
that that's pretty good 266. I'm a
little high I mean that's still really
impressive yeah yeah so I figure a good
way to start this would be how this all
happened from the start it was
interesting because we were at Mr
BEAST's warehouse and I went to go use
the restroom and on my way to the
bathroom I kind of lock eyes with you
for a second and I was like oh my gosh
that's Jimmy darts and I just oh my gosh
that's Jack by coincidence
but yeah I was just walking to the
bathroom and I saw you I was like oh my
gosh this is Jimmy what a coincidence I
was not expecting to see you here
because I've seen you on my Tick Tock
for you page on YouTube you've been
blowing up recently crazy views
unprecedented views and uh I was like
okay I'm not gonna say anything I'm not
gonna bother him he's probably busy and
I kind kind of like stop there for a
second and slow down then I start
walking back to the bathroom someone
comes up to me and they're like hey have
you met Jimmy darts and I said no he
said come meet him nicest guy ever
you're a very nice guy you're just the
same as you are on camera as in person
you are so friendly by the way yeah it's
just like really nice and just like
happy all the time yeah yeah I think
yeah it was super random running into
you guys and I loved it because I don't
know if I'd ever run into you guys
because I'm not in the YouTube Finance
kind of space and stuff and I have
friends that are friends with a lot of
craters but I don't know anyone that
knew you guys personally so to run into
you guys and I was like what the heck
it's been really cool too because I've
seen your videos and I I've heard your
voice before it's always the voice put
the face to the voice but I remember
scrolling tick tocks and seeing your
videos come up and the one that really
stands out the most is it was a lady in
the electric wheelchair with the black
eyes yeah she she took a fall and you
gave her money yes uh and that video got
how many views yeah that was crazy that
got like I don't know 35 million or 8 38
million on Tick Tock yeah I don't know
like maybe 15 million on YouTube I don't
know exact numbers but it went crazy
yeah and that was wild that was actually
um so I live in California I live in LA
in that area now and I'm from Minnesota
though a small town of like 900 people
so I decided to go back home this summer
and I was super worried I was like how
am I gonna make videos here everyone
knows who I am but there's a little town
that's like 40 minutes away that has a
Walmart My Town doesn't even have a
Walmart so I go to this little town
there and I'm like all right can I make
content in some a town this small you
know and I go in there and the first
thought I had was I was like let's get a
piggy bank fill it with money and a
hammer and walk around and uh smash it
open for the first person that gives me
five dollars to to guess what's inside
you know so I was like if you give me
five dollars you can have what's in here
it could be a cent could be a thousand
dollars and I'm walking around Walmart
and everyone's just staring at me
because they see a hammer and a pigment
going in front like this and uh sure
enough I go up to this lady
and uh she didn't have five dollars but
I just my heart broke it's like this 80
some year old 70 some year old lady in
this uh electric wheelchair and her eyes
all black she had just like fallen on
the pavement
um she's like I wish I could give you
the money for it but I'm broke right now
and I was like all right why don't you
just have it and so I go to give it to
her and then the Walmart like manager
comes and kicks me out of the store he's
like you can't be doing that in here
like with the piggy bank and all this so
he kicks us out and I go wait for her
outside and then she um ends up coming
after she shops comes outside she said I
didn't think you'd wait for me she
thought I was gonna leave and so I stay
there wait for her give her the piggy
bank
um for free she smashed it open oh it
comes 500 and she starts freaking out
crying she just explains that they're
going through a hard time financially
and it was just it was wild and
basically after that happened I was like
dang let's try to go the extra mile with
this lady and see if we can help her and
her husband so I just made a GoFundMe
that night posted the video and I didn't
know if people would donate you know
maybe a thousand dollars two thousand
well it ended up being like I think over
ninety thousand dollars oh my came in
first yeah it was in the news like the
newspaper everything and it was crazy
then I go back to that Walmart a few
days later and I shot a video in there
again I'm pulling out and the Walmart uh
like manager comes chasing after me I'm
like oh no I was about to hit the gas
you know I was like I don't want to get
yelled at right now so I'm like all
right I'm just gonna stop let's just
confront the situation and he goes wait
one second he goes I am so sorry for
kicking you out I had no idea who you
are what you guys are doing come to my
store anytime so it was a good
Redemption moment that was so cool yeah
where did you get the idea to start
doing this yeah I mean I I've always
kind of as ever since I was a little kid
my parents for Christmas would give us
200 they'd say 100 is for you a hundred
dollars is to give away to somebody so
right then I just became comfortable
with people on the streets with
strangers just hearing their story
giving them money kind of doing that and
then the first time I really realized
the power of the internet you know to be
able to crowdfun and stuff was I was in
Miami me on the beach and there was this
homeless guy living in a tent and I go
up to him I say hey bro do you want to
be best friends for the day and have
some fun and he's like sure and so we
basically go rollerblading play
basketball do some fun stuff like this
and on the way home I'm making a tick
tock of this and he starts like kind of
tearing up and he goes dang bro like I
was planning on committing inside and
this like changed my whole perspective
on life I was like oh my gosh like I had
no idea I was just having a good time
like having fun with you and I was like
dang like I want to see if I can raise
some money for you bro like to help you
get off the street like this is crazy so
I made a GoFundMe for him and back then
I didn't even really have that many
followers and sure enough overnight I
almost I I didn't almost delete the
video but the video I posted it it had
like it was like one of the worst
performing videos ever and I was like
damn man I wanted this to go viral to
raise some money for this guy but then I
wake up the next morning it's got like
15 million views and he had raised like
over 20 some 30 000-ish for him
um so yeah he he just changed his life
he went in like two words South America
and stuff and uh it was just powerful
what can happen
um when when you when you show there's a
lot of people that want to donate they
just don't always know how or where to
give you know so what gave you that idea
to go up to that guy in particular film
it yeah put it on Tick Tock where did
you get the inspiration for that uh he
was just chilling on the beach he was
just having a good time hanging out
there so he just looked like an approach
no guy but back to your main question
kind of how I came up with this idea to
have people pass a kindness test and
that's kind of what I do now is I was in
California I'm walking and I was like
man instead of just giving people money
or doing something like that like what
if I asked for help first and so there
were this awesome uh family coming
across the crosswalk and there was like
four kids and Mom and Dad and I said hey
do you guys have any money for food I'm
really hungry right now I just just
don't have any cash and they go sure and
they come out they give me a couple
dollars and they give me a burrito out
of the backpack and I was like actually
I was just seeing the first person to
help me here's a hundred dollars that's
all I was doing at the time I was like
here's a hundred bucks to reward your
kindness and he starts freaking out like
tearing up and it just like rocked their
life and I was like oh my gosh this is
such a cool way to not only bless
awesome people and go to areas where
there's people in need but also to find
people that have probably been generous
their whole life that's the thing with
these people that I find it's not like
they just happen to help me that day
they've probably been pulling money out
of their pocket for 50 years you know
helping people never got recognized for
it never got rewarded for it and so
that's my favorite part about it's like
man getting to reward someone that's
probably been kind their whole life yeah
what were you doing before this I mean
I've been making videos ever since I was
a kid I was always doing videos
um just whatever I could if it was Baby
Jesus in the manger when I was like six
years old like have it playing with him
in the Legos or whatever I was always
doing just different videos and then
when I was 18 17 18 I kind of started
partying a lot and I didn't really get
into drugs or alcohol that kind of
always scared me but I would just do
wild stuff you know like I don't make
out with a girl or you know I get drunk
maybe three four times stuff like this
but I would always love to do crazy
stuff like like just run through a wall
or like I don't know type stuff you know
have you ran through a wall yeah I mean
I've done a lot of stuff
does that have to go to parties and
every time I was at a party
um I would start punching myself in the
face till I was covered in blood my nose
used to bleed easily and I'd be covered
in blood and everyone at the party would
freak out I just I just loved uh
I love hyping okay and all this stuff
right and um I just yeah I just love
crazy stuff and long story short when I
was 18 years old I went to this party in
Minnesota out in the middle of the woods
you know it's super cold out there so
they have fires you know bonfires people
hang out in the woods I go out there
with these Jesus socks on I had like a
little Jesus on them from Urban
Outfitters like a little statue on the
side and I'm out there and I'm just
messing around being stupid whatever and
jumping over the fire like showing off
just doing some dumb stuff and on the
way home that night I was like oh crap
my socks have holes in them my parents
are gonna find out I've been partying
like they don't know that I live this
lifestyle like they think I'm like this
kind of perfect kid I was so freaked out
and so I sneak up to my room and I'm
like if I throw my socks away my mom
does the laundry she'll know there was a
pair missing I was like I have to think
fast and I don't know why I thought of
it but I literally take my socks off I'm
like I wasn't drunk or had any drugs
that night nothing just completely clear
her mind just didn't want her to know I
was living that kind of rebellious
lifestyle it's like Jesus please uh
please help my socks like heal my socks
I hide them in the back of my underwear
drawer go to bed the next morning I wake
up before my mom comes upstairs to do
the laundry grab the socks and they're
brand new same spot I've left them no
holes in them and I freak out and I'm
like oh my gosh like the first thought
that came to my mind is I thought God
would have been mad at me wanted me to
get caught wanted me to get in trouble
but as soon as I grabbed those socks I
just felt him speak to me and he's like
actually Jimmy I want to be your friend
above everything else like I want to be
your friend before anything and that
really impacted me and and and really
changed my life at first you want to
thank our sponsor Ron Graham did you
mean to wear that today I did did you
mean to wear that I did I think you knew
I was wearing this and wanted to match
not this again Jack this is a mess we
gotta fix it
there we go see that's better as someone
who works from home and is constantly
hopping on and off Zoom calls it's
difficult to find a balance between
looking professional and also just being
in your pajamas that was the case
however before I found Roan when Ron
first sent us their commuter shirt I
honestly could not believe how
breathable it was for a dress shirt yeah
it's actually really unusual to find a
shirt that you could look professional
in and then immediately after go and run
a marathon in my favorite part about
Rhone is that they use wrinkle release
technology so all wrinkles will just
disappear as you stretch and wear the
shirt which is perfect for me
considering I don't even own an iron
plus with their gold Fusion anti-odor
technology you'll smell fresh and clean
all day long regardless of how sweaty
you are sponsorship aside it's
incredibly comfy I was surprised when I
put this on that it feels like Silk that
was the first thing you said I did yeah
yeah there you go guys uh honest review
from me it feels incredible Ron is 100
machine washable so no more expensive
and time-consuming trips to the dry
cleaners the commuter shirt can get you
through anywhere workday and straight
into whatever comes next so head to
rhone.com iced coffee and get 20 off
your entire order with the code iced
coffee that's twenty percent off your
entire order when you head to rhoney.com
iced coffee and use code iced coffee at
checkout it's that easy enjoy thank you
guys so much and now let's get back to
the podcast a few months after that um
my entire life I had horrible scoliosis
so my spine was very crooked my left leg
was this much shorter than my right leg
I used to walk like this people would
make fun of me and stuff and um so so
after high school you know from that
soccer experience it was so radical
um my parents were like Jimmy if you
want to go to Hawaii we'll pay for your
school you can go out there to this
little Christian school for like six
months and I was like all right do I do
that or do I go to UCLA kind of party
and stuff get into film and video like
what do I do and I was like Hawaii
sounds kind of dope so I go to Hawaii
and I'm out there and basically like a
month into the school this guy comes up
to me hey Jimmy can I pray for your like
scoliosis I was like what like pray for
me what are you talking about he's like
to get healed and I was like what are
you talking about bro like I spent my
whole life going to doctors
chiropractors everything and no one's
been able to like how are you gonna heal
my back you know and the doctors were
going to lengthen my achilles tenant and
my leg so my legs would be the same
length but it'd be a long surgery it's
going to be in a wheelchair for like six
months and anyways I'm in Hawaii sitting
there and this gentleman he goes all
right let's watch this I want to pray
for you so I sit down in a chair he
holds my legs out like this and he goes
watch this in Jesus name be healed right
now and my leg starts shaking and goes
straight out to match the length of my
other leg and my back is fully healed my
spine is straight and that really just
changed my life forever and from that
point I gave my life fully to Jesus I
stopped like living for myself stop
partying all that stuff and that's
really the the motive and the the force
behind all these videos and everything
is is basically that you know it's so
it's a combination of the socks and the
leg Yeah that gave you yeah the belief
now that you're gonna this is the right
path to do you're gonna full force on
this yeah and so I I was making videos
back then doing party videos I don't
know if you guys remember like I'm
smacked but they'd go around all right
they do these wild party videos and I
started doing party videos like that and
so I had around 18 000 subscribers like
30 000 followers on Twitter and I had
built up my socials and after this
happened where I got healed met and had
this Encounter With Jesus
um I just felt like he was speaking to
me and I was I just he was just like do
you are you gonna surrender that like
can you surrender your videos you've
given me all these other things but your
videos like it's still an idol in your
life you know and that's where I had put
all my eggs were in one basket and I was
like you know what like I don't feel
like I would ever be old and regret
giving everything to God surrendering
everything and so I sat there like 18
years old with my videos pulled up
everything
and I was like dang he's right and so I
went and deleted everything and then it
said are you sure you want to delete I
was like oh my gosh and I hit delete and
uh every video I had was deleted my
Channel all my followers and then I uh
how many followers do you have back then
uh back then I had like 18 000 on
YouTube like 30 000 Twitter that's
pretty that's pretty good yeah yeah it's
like eight years ago so what sort of
videos like existed just party Wild
video like I would just go through a
wall like Steve will do it yeah
just colleges or high schools and and
Jimmy will do it yeah yeah yeah no I
would just make montages of people
partying and just all kinds of stuff
like that and I really as soon as I
deleted everything
um I felt like I I felt horrible the
first month I felt like I didn't exist
my identity was so in that was so
wrapped up in that and um for about a
month and a half I felt horrible and
after that month passed then I actually
felt more known and better than ever and
it was because I was no owned by God and
not by men and I was approved by him and
not like this validation you get from
people that change and like you and
don't like you and so kind of went on
that Journey for three four years and
then I felt like he said to get back
into videos and that it was time and so
I started this about a year and a half
ago and it just kind of took off we're
going to college
um no I was uh I was going to different
Ministry schools so I went to elementary
school and in uh California and Hawaii
be funny if you said no I just went to
Hawaii yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so the
only thing that kind of like I mean
there are lots that sticks out to me but
especially was the fact that like you
said you were going to parties and like
doing these crazy sounds like punching
yourself in the face until you bled and
was that just to see the reaction of
people to like so they can watch you do
that yeah I don't know I just loved wild
things you know since I wasn't really
getting drunk or doing like drugs or
anything like that I just wanted to be
involved with the party and like you
know just just get it could be the life
of the party you do that like everyone's
gonna be yo you see what gym
it was crazy and and uh and yeah I think
it just comes from uh an identity of not
knowing who I was you know not really
knowing god not having a relationship
with him and you just just kind of
confused but
um but yeah basically during those three
four years like I was saying when I when
I left the internet and off all that
stuff I moved to Texas Austin Texas
I was actually driving in my car in
Minnesota not sure what to do with my
life should I go to Texas California had
opportunities both and I felt like God
spoke to me said Jimmy if it's 96
degrees in Austin Texas right now I want
you to move there and I was like what
the heck so I pull out my phone I look
it up Austin Texas it's 96 degrees so
I'm like oh my gosh like all right and I
moved there like two weeks later and I
moved there and um I'm working at a
restaurant staying in this apartment and
I'm like literally like broke like I
could barely eat out or like you know
get groceries like it was pretty tight
and um I asked I I was asked talking to
God and I was just like where should we
work out you know and there was a gym at
the apartment I was staying at but I
felt like I was supposed to ask him that
and I felt like he said go to Lifetime
Fitness and I was like
he's sponsored by LifeTime Fitness by
the way
they have a 50 off coupon yeah so I was
so confused I was like oh I bet it's
like 80 a month there I was like I can't
afford to go to Lifetime Fitness and so
I ended up going there and during this
whole time when I left the internet I
really got into e-commerce started
learning about Amazon different Drop
Shipping businesses and that was my
dream was just to like have an online
business and I watched this guy
religiously his name was uh Ryan Moran
and he went zero to a million dollars on
um Amazon in a year and so I watched all
his videos was learning from this guy
and I show up to Lifetime Fitness like
why did God lead me here and I'm signing
the contract the lock-in for a year deal
or whatever and I look up there he is in
the lobby on the phone this guy and so I
go up to him I'm like oh my gosh bro
like I've watched your stuff about
business I love it like like uh can you
teach me or anything like can you Mentor
me and he's and he's like well come to
my conference yeah I was like all right
he's like it's a capitalism conference I
was like how much is it he's like 3 000
a person I was like oh my gosh well I
can't go to that and so I asked him I'm
like well where is it and he's like it's
at the JW Marriott Downtown Austin I was
like that's where I work so I couldn't
afford to get in it but I was at the
restaurant on as a server and I was
picking the brains of all these
e-commerce people and really learning a
lot from them and then that kind of
launched me into starting my own Amazon
business and it still runs today and and
ever since then I haven't had to like
work a nine to five or anything like
that I've just kind of had that job and
uh what's really crazy is this is about
four four or five years ago a month ago
I was raising funds in Minnesota for a
video and I'm reading I I was reading
the person who was donating every day
there's different people that donate um
because I do it on a live stream all my
videos are crowdfunded so
um most of my videos are so I usually go
on a live stream I say what's up guys
we're gonna try to bless so-and-so today
here's my venmo I'm gonna be giving
shout outs to everyone that donates
whether it be a cent ten dollars it's
all appreciate all adds up and this guy
donates on the stream and I was like
what the heck is that that must be a
fake account and I look and it was the
real Ryan Moran and we start messaging
and he follows me now and uh we've
actually been calling back and forth
voice memoing and uh he wants to do
something with me where potentially like
um maybe equity in a company and I
promote it or something like this but
it's a really wild full circle moment
that is you know tell us about this
Amazon business what were you selling
yeah I was selling uh I tried everything
so I failed like five times I tried
selling like most traps to like dog
water water bowls that you would squeeze
out of a bottle all this stuff is that
the one you take in the car yeah yeah um
oh really yeah it's not the squeeze one
it's a battery-powered one you press it
and it goes into this compartment yeah
and Bailey drinks from it and then it
goes right back exactly a little bit
it's amazing yeah I like this yeah I was
selling those like crazy fidget Spinners
but it was just such a weird uh industry
because you get your account taken down
or like I don't know it's very weird
like uh that e-commerce stuff unless you
create the product but eventually
the product that I end up landing on was
just like cleaning supplies I want to
keep it kind of broad because Amazon is
still like an Undiscovered space still
doing it yes I am yeah yeah can you tell
us like how much you're making from that
right now we're not going to say the
product yeah yeah it's not a crazy
amount you know but it's enough to like
pay bills and stuff like this it brings
in like 3 000 a month so it's fantastic
and it's just autonomous you know really
yeah so what's your involvement day to
day uh nothing I mean I have I have
someone that works with me like I have
an assistant that does a lot of stuff
with me
um who's my brother-in-law and just once
every couple weeks you'll check it
reorder but it's very simple process and
it's been doing a hundred dollars a day
for years yeah for like four years are
you serious yeah did you just rank
really high on a certain product
um yeah yeah yeah well it was uh very so
when you watch a lot of these uh uh
e-commerce Amazon videos they'll all try
to get you making like a thousand
dollars a day or five thousand dollars a
day I was like I could I don't want to
make that much a day I always want to
make 80 to 100 dollars a day and have
little competition and so I found a
product that there's only like two other
people selling it you know
um but I basically went into it created
my little logo took photos and yeah it
just sells on its own and
a couple years ago I thought I was going
to lose the whole thing because a guy
copied me exactly took my photos Took
The Branding everything but it still
sells and and yeah it was it was pretty
awesome it's a great way to be like if
you could have an online business you
have so much free time to pursue what
you're passionate about versus you know
yeah did sales go down once someone else
joined the the pool yeah they did so
then it was kind of this price War where
it was like you know yeah lower in our
price this and that
um and then when covet happened the
sales went to almost zero because all
like the restaurants and hotels were
kind of shut down so I was like yeah I
was like not making a single dollar
doing anything and it was it was crazy
that was my whole business and um but
then after covet it kind of started back
up again and yeah it's it's a it's a
Amazon is a great tool to have but I
wouldn't fully depend on it for anything
just because so what's stopping you from
going and finding other products like
that and just copying them do what that
guy did to you yeah
I just hate that like copying anything
you know like I just feel like the way
God has made us and knitted each of us
like worse we can be so creative and so
individualized in the way we like I feel
like we each have like a gift that
someone else doesn't have you know and
so you could sure do that but then I
don't know it's just it's just a weird
business and it's it's just not too
reliable you know like videos is my main
passion doing stuff like that and I just
have the Amazon business because it just
yeah it's consistent yeah it's good
how'd you meet Mr Beast how did I meet
him how did that happen yeah so it was
crazy his uh I don't know his his
account manager for tick tock is this
guy named Rohan yeah and uh some of my
old roommates yeah he's awesome guys so
my old roommates flow out there to do uh
some videos with them and he didn't know
I was living with these guys um we live
in like a bunch of tick talkers and
stuff and uh he just message me he's
like yo Jimmy you wanna come make some
videos with us I was like yes I'll come
like I'll do anything to come so it was
really awesome I got to go out there and
we shot two tick tocks was that the day
that we met you yeah yeah went out there
it was awesome man Jimmy is he's so cool
Mr B tell us about that day I Saw The
Tick Tock and I heard about the idea
before you did it I was like man that's
crazy because uh what was it went to a
was it a Walmart yeah yeah went to a
Walmart and handed people how much was
it you explain it yeah yeah it was crazy
yeah basically we went into Walmart
um and gave people option would you
rather have a thousand dollars cash for
yourself or and then he opened a
briefcase ten thousand dollars to give
away to someone random in the store and
people were looking at it and they're
like oh my gosh and the first two people
chose the thousand dollars we said all
right bless you have a good day and then
finally someone's like I'll give 10 000
away so it's crazy because the way the
video started there was these two moms
kind of in an area and we only went up
to one because we went up we could only
choose one to talk to at that moment and
there was one lady she chose the
thousand dollars which was it was
awesome because she needed the money but
she could have given the ten thousand
that lady there so it's kind of sad that
she didn't get the money but but we're
like all right and we end up in the
store going up to this guy saying you
want a thousand dollars or ten thousand
giveaway he goes I'll give away ten
thousand dollars we go all right you got
20 seconds so he's running through the
store people everywhere and he could
have given it to anyone and he randomly
goes up to the other mom that didn't get
the money before gives her 10K and then
we said hey because you chose to be kind
give ten thousand away we want to give
10 000 to you as well and the whole
Walmart at that place was just it was
nuts there was like 100 people just like
mobbing us and we had to get off yeah
that's what I was really curious about
because they said that uh you know I
would imagine Mr Beast goes into
anywhere in that location and he's
immediately gonna be recognized
everyone's gonna be like yo she's here
he's here let's show up and everyone's
gonna ask for money exactly yeah it was
crazy because when I go out and shoot my
video sometimes I'm paranoid I like
sometimes will wear like a covet mask up
here a hat like I just don't want anyone
to know it's me and get an ingenuine
reaction and but with him it was insane
and we were in his hometown so like like
it was we were running through aisles
kids were like chasing us trying to get
pictures and we're like not now like and
um yeah it ended up being like 80 people
in the store and we had to get him out
of there but I I can't imagine you know
so it's disguised yeah you think he
needs a disguise well he did that
recently or something like that well he
did that recently for his Mr Beast
Burger he went and he showed up in like
an all blacked out suit with like a
hoodie and everything yeah and then if
you get a close enough look I'm sure he
was wearing a mask and a hat too yeah in
his hometown you know he was into some
town and that's what I do for a lot of
my videos is I almost never go up to
younger people because they'll at least
if they don't follow me they've seen a
video whatever so try to go up to like
older people that maybe don't ever go on
the internet so if you go out I'm sure
this has probably happened at some point
in the past where you'll go out and ask
someone and they recognize you and they
choose to do like the moral thing all
right whatever you know the ethical
thing giving you money or whatever
you're asking for uh have you like what
has that experience been like going out
yeah I can usually read people pretty
well and tell if they recognize me or
not you know and um but I did have an
instance recently I was at this Walmart
and I'll go up to this lady I was like
I'm trying to buy this food for my kid
like do you have an extra dollar two
four and she goes no I don't I was like
you sure she goes nope and I go all
right thank you and I walk away and a
minute later she comes chases me down
she goes oh I got money for you and I
was like what I thought you didn't
happen she goes oh no I found something
and she had this crazy look in her eyes
I was like oh I think I'm good actually
like I'm good she's like you sure I was
like yeah I'm just I'm feeling good so I
left the store but yeah so it's it's
happened a couple times now have you
ever given money to someone who you feel
maybe later didn't deserve it or maybe
they weren't the intended recipient of
that maybe you give them money and then
they go off to their brand new Porsche
right you know yeah I mean honestly I
will tell you this like sometimes I've
done a couple of videos where
um wealthy people have passed the
kindness test and they've gotten
rewarded and it's something I really
enjoy and really love is because they
never like like some some wealthy people
they're always expected when they're out
to dinner they have to pay for the meal
they have to do this and so when they
get given something it really can just
freak them out in their mind and the
whole point isn't just to give them
finances but it's like it's to do
something to their heart you know and
I've seen that happen a few times where
yeah some wealthy people have gotten the
funds and they're just so impacted by it
that
um I just believe it changes their life
but for the most part you know it's it's
whatever the person chooses to do with
the money like I can't follow them home
and say make sure you do it like this
spend this and that just kind of go up
to people feel led and you know if they
pass the kindness test like you know
it's they're responsible kind of for
what the money does but for the most
part I usually try to find people
um that you know are just working people
that are just having a hard goal at life
you know and and um and yeah but what's
an instance you can think back on where
someone passed and exceeded your
kindness test by like times ten let's
say you asked for like a dollar or a
little snack and they like take you out
to some super fancy dinner yeah yeah oh
man a kindness test that was exceeded
um I I the only one I can think of of
the top of my head is just this this guy
um I was doing a video first person uh
give me a hug was gonna get five five
hundred dollars so I drove around town
all day and I was praying I was like
Jesus Lead Me to the right person pops
and was driving and every time I was
about to go up to someone and give him a
hug I just didn't feel good about it and
I was like that's not the right person
and I ended up driving home I was like I
guess I'm not shooting a video today and
boom there's a guy riding his bike on
the sidewalk and I was like that's the
guy he was just he was like glowing I
just felt like that was him so I pulled
the car over run in front of his bike
I'm like sir sir he stops the bike with
his feet because the brakes didn't work
and I go could I have a hug I just had a
bad day just I just man I just missed my
family and he gets off his bike gives me
a hug and I say thank you so much sir
I've seen the first person be kind
enough to care and give me a hug and I'm
gonna bless you with 500 and I said it's
a grown man and he starts weeping right
there and he's like today at work the
boss paid everyone except for me and
then he just went into explaining that
he was a immigrant from El Salvador and
he moved to the US 18 years ago to send
money to his family his wife and kids to
survive because the economy was so rough
there and he's not able to go back
because then he can't get back in the
U.S so he's just been face timing his
wife and kids for 18 years hasn't seen
him and uh and I was just like oh my
gosh this is crazy like I I want to do
more with this guy we actually became
really good friends and we went on a
tour helping people out so we drove to
like Vegas Utah like we would hit like
four or five states me and this guy
staying in the same hotel rooms like
yeah me and this dude his name was Jose
we just became awesome friends doing
this and we were doing news shows like
uh yeah we'd be on the news and
different things like that and then I
ended up
um raising like I think it was around 60
000 in total for him and the money for
him it was enough for him he moved back
home this year in time for Christmas to
be with his family permanently and uh he
said he could buy a house in El Salvador
for ten thousand dollars so he's got
enough for like five houses so he's
doing well he's business minded so his
whole life is back on track now he he's
back with his family and yeah it was
just just an amazing story you know just
like you never know what someone's going
through and just it's just I want to
find the next Jose because he's out
there right now somewhere you know do
you ever worry that people might not be
truthful about their story and maybe you
end up raising money for somebody who's
who's you know lying about it
exaggerating their downfall yeah so for
the most part you know
um we usually the videos if they pass a
kindness test they'll get a thousand
dollars or five hundred dollars this or
that but once in a while you know uh
maybe a couple times a month we'll do a
GoFundMe or whatever and raise 50 to 100
000 but anytime we do that we really get
to know the person
um yeah we talk to them a lot and just
relationally you know we don't just say
all right we're gonna set up a GoFundMe
reminds me of uh the story remember that
this was back in like 2013 or 14 Josh
paler Lynn raised money for a homeless
man and I had no idea if that video was
was fake I have the heat I've met with
him before and he's told me it's it's a
hundred percent legit yeah
um I I don't have any proof either way
right but he raised money for him I
think it was like a hundred grand it was
something like this this was one of the
first YouTube videos to really like a
viral viral viral and
um the guy was an alcoholic and The
Story Goes that he got access to all of
this money and drank himself to death
yeah that's crazy so I mean do you do
you ever think that maybe there could be
something where you would have to get
more involved other than just uh yeah
100 I'm actually in that same situation
currently actually right now I met this
gentleman
um in Huntington Beach a couple weeks
ago he was just awesome guy he passed
the kindness test he was homeless and I
was talking to him and you could tell he
wasn't on drugs and maybe a little bit
alcohol it may be something like that
but nothing it didn't seem nothing too
serious and so we ended up making a
GoFundMe for him and uh we raised like
50 60 000 but then we uh I don't know
somehow his brother reached out to us or
he gave us his brother's contact and his
his brother is an awesome guy like a
Christian family man he's got kids and
he lives in the area and he began to
tell us the story of this guy where his
brother's been homeless for 20 some
years he's an alcoholic and he's like
scared that he'll end up drinking
himself to death you know and it's sad
he stays with his family like once a
week he'll go stay with his brother you
know but
um so it's it's a tricky situation so
we're not going to give all those funds
to him we actually set it up where it's
like a joint thing with his brother and
uh and him and us to where like we're
just going to use these funds to
possibly get him off the street into a
hotel or apartment and then just kind of
gauge where he's at you know because a
lot of these people we've in the last
year I've gotten like three to four
homeless people fully off the street and
these are not these are people that were
literally heroin addicts like straight
up hair like heroin addicts and I've
gotten them off the street to where they
don't do drugs they have a car they're
living their life and the reason we've
been able to do that isn't just handing
somebody money but it's relationally
getting to know him and having fun with
them and so that's one of the main
things is when you ask these people like
Adam why do you drink and it's like well
if most people had to sleep outside
every night you know had no family had
none of this like they would resort to
something like that you know like when
people don't feel connected you know
that's when they feel empty and that's
when they try to find things to fill
that so if you can fill that connection
void in somebody's life you can actually
break off some of these addictions and
then kind of begin to rehabilitate them
off the street you know I worry there'd
also be some physical dependencies on on
certain substances that you know might
temporarily they might be able to you
know hold it through but that long term
without consistent treatment
um you know it could be
in a slippery slope yeah yeah definitely
I mean at the end of the day you know
you never fully know you know everyone
has free will they can choose to do
whatever they want to do but the key is
just to always believe the best in
people and really just not give somebody
money unwisely but try to do your best
to know their story get to know who they
are and uh yeah find out what the root
causes are of what they're going through
and try to and try to help them out one
of my favorite examples was this this
homeless gentleman named Tom I met him
about uh probably about a year ago and
um and yeah I asked him to play
hopscotch with me and he's like
Hopscotch what do you want me to play
hopscotch I was like yeah I'm just
seeing the first person to have fun and
play hopscotch so he did and I reward
his kindness for 500 for being childlike
and he began sharing his story and long
story short yeah he was going through
some different things probably some drug
addiction some different things like
that and I bought him a cell phone to
help uh stay connected with him and was
gonna try getting him off the street and
I reached out to him a week later his
cell phone's gone I'm like what happened
to your cell phone he's like oh somebody
stole it or something so I'm like all
right I'll believe you this time like
get him another phone so I get him
another phone same thing happens a few
weeks later it's like all right he could
be selling this phone to get substances
or something like that you know and it's
a it's a tricky thing like do we just
leave him do we stop talking but it's
like no it's like I felt God's heart for
Him that God really cared about him and
people probably only giving him two
chances but this man needed endless
chances and so we just kept relentlessly
becoming his friend I take him go
karting
um take him to like a baseball game just
different things like that at becoming
friends with them and sure enough uh we
got him new teeth we ripped us he's got
them brand new teeth and that just
brought a whole new joy to him just
looking good in the mirror and then we
uh yeah we raised like 30 some thousand
dollars for him and actually found him a
full-time job he's been working full
time for the past eight months living
with the people who own the business
caretaking their house doing all this
stuff clean off everything and he's just
loving life loving his job and he's like
yeah he's one of their best employees
ever so it's crazy I call him still once
in a while hang out with him and it's
just it's insane right because once you
see somebody like you know misuse what
use them once you sometimes you want to
give up on them but sometimes what these
people need is just like somebody just
really love love them you know just love
them crazy how do you maintain
relationships with so many people yeah
it's very difficult my phone is ringing
like every 20 minutes from a random
number I'm like who's number like every
time I do a video I usually give the
purse is my number you know
um but yeah I just try to do the best I
can you know it's me and one other
person that kind of does these videos
with me and yeah we just are relational
with them sometimes you know we just
talk to them on the phone or go hang out
with them but really they've all be kind
of come friends you know like uh they're
just they're just awesome people you
know and uh yeah like God God's created
everyone so cool and so unique you know
and I just know that a lot of times the
reason people are the way they are isn't
because they necessarily chose it but
something happened to them when they
were a little kid or this had their
parents did this to him and it kind of
forms these thought patterns and this
Behavior to where it leaves them there
but really it's just an awesome person
that just if you go a little bit deeper
in some layers you'll find gold in them
yeah and they're some of the best people
ever do you ever have people reaching
back out asking for more money sometimes
you know not not really not a lot of the
time but sometimes and yeah we just you
know it's it's we use wisdom you know so
we're not like oh here we'll send you
another five thousand it's like hey we
gave you some funds you're responsible
with it and if you didn't use it in a
good way that's sad but we wish the best
for you we'll talk with you pray with
you but but yeah 95 percent of the time
99 of the time that's never that doesn't
really happen you know yeah so here's a
here's a philosophical question yeah do
you believe that there are just by
Nature evil people that exist like
someone that can be born just with like
malicious intent or a nefarious person
that just wants bad on others yeah I
think to answer your question truthfully
I think that's every single one of us I
think we're all born into sin we're all
born selfishly as soon as you're like
two years old you're stealing your toy
from another baby crying if it's not
yours and we just kind of grow up and
live this selfish lifestyle and
eventually you know we try to cover that
up and you know make sometimes make it
seem like we're better people this and
that but at the end of the day I think
the main thing is just really just yeah
just surrender gender in your life like
when I when I saw Jesus and saw his love
for me I was like dang like I'm selfish
I live for myself I do all these things
for myself like I need to know him and
what happened is when when God came into
my life he didn't just say all right
Jimmy conform to all these rules right
now and do this even though you don't
want to do this no it's like once I got
in a place of surrender it felt like he
ripped out my heart and gave me a new
heart that desired new things it's like
my taste buds changed so I desired to
live righteous instead of felt obligated
to do it you know so it's not like Jimmy
don't go drink don't do this don't hook
up with people it's not it's more like I
just don't even want to do it like you
couldn't give me right now fifty
thousand dollars to like say a cuss word
like I just I just don't want to do that
and and to answer your question kind of
it's just like I believe yeah we all
have free will you know and we can we
can choose whatever we want but I feel
like yeah like God makes everybody and
is is it says in the Bible that it's
God's will for all men to be saved and
what that word saved means is saved
healed delivered said free and so his
heart really for people is to know him
to be loved to come into his family and
and um and yeah I don't know if that
answers the question but it does but I'm
also curious is there anyone that you've
tried to help and you've been
consistently disappointed in them or
just really surprised at what they had
done after you tried to help them in a
bad way and you've had to like give up
on them yeah like for example one of the
situations is this this gentleman I was
just talking to you about with the
alcohol addiction like I was telling him
I was like man like we want to help you
out but you got to say no to the alcohol
you know and he keeps choosing the L
call over wanting help and so we're not
gonna Force anything on them but we're
just gonna keep praying for him and and
yeah at the end of the day he has full
freedom to do whatever he wants you know
and so you can never control people or
force them to do something but it's just
believe the best in people and it's it's
really crazy what you can see like
sometimes just enough love will just
shatter someone's heart and I just
believe all people can be changed and
all people can be forgiven given and
we've all done things wrong on a
different measure but at the end of the
day we just need God's love his
forgiveness and when he does that he
really can do a work in us you know I'm
going to shift the topic a little bit
get back to finance
I'm so curious how taxes work you're
saying you're raising money on venmo and
people are venmoing you
I'm worried maybe venmo is going to
report that to the IRS you're going to
be giving money out to people without a
1099 and then you're going to be on the
hook for a huge tax bill with money that
you've already given away yeah has that
been factored in yeah so I have an
accountant that kind of goes through
some of these things and stuff like that
but yeah it's a poor account manager
yeah
like you gave 500 to who and you're like
I don't know you gave me a hug yeah okay
what about this guy I don't know he gave
me a dollar so I gave him a thousand
yeah yeah it's a very complicated uh
situation because yeah uh the it's it's
it's weird but yeah the the donations
they come in like they're they're
counted as like income so we have to set
about a certain aside away for taxes for
that and stuff but um but yeah really we
just
um yeah it's a large amount like there's
something where if it's 500 or like
under 599 you can just give someone that
cash and if it's more if it's like a car
or a crazy thing then you have to fill
out the these different forms and stuff
you're going to have a tax nightmare I'm
going to tell you you're going to have
one really good year where it it's one
of two situations is going to happen one
it's an audit because you're writing up
so much of your income they're seeing so
much money come in and immediately flow
out in cash it's a big flag or two
you're gonna be stuck in a situation
where all of a sudden the IRS says hey
Jimmy you owe us 500 000 and you say I
don't have the 500 yeah well that's the
thing so yeah I made sure to set aside
for taxes with everything you know so I
have the taxes set aside for that yeah
like whenever I get paid even for if
it's something on my own I just will set
aside the tax and just count everything
as income you know because I'm going to
give you the boring answer you're
probably not going to want to hear it
everybody you give money to you got to
get a 10.99 you got to get them to to
get an ID a name an address a social
security number if they don't have it
then it's at your discretion yeah but
keep records of that for sure and keep
keep it under the amount you just yeah I
feel like it'd be hard to do that with
homeless people yeah but that's why I'm
singing keep it under that amount but
they should still have well I would
imagine most would have a Social
Security yeah yeah it's interesting yeah
we've talked many tax people yeah like
it can some of it can be down like as
educational purposes and you can give
funds to people in need without having
to uh report some of those you know
things but make sure you get that
buttoned up right yeah something happen
yeah we're working right now we're
trying to form right now like a
non-profit working through those things
and it's just crazy how much stuff you
have to fill out for that and stuff but
I have a question about that too and uh
Jimmy I also want to let you know that
our official card sponsor is Lexus
yeah yeah but uh you know my question I
remember Mr B said on a podcast that um
at first he when he was giving out money
um you know he would also help people
pay the tax on it so like even though he
would give away let's say five thousand
dollars it would be more because there
would be more money set aside for taxes
so that they could like net five
thousand yeah
um and then I remember he mentioned that
he had to switch that up because of it
the taxes
um when you give away large things or
cars or whatever you're giving away
um especially the larger stuff do you
kind of help these people plan for that
or or how does that work yeah for sure
yeah definitely anytime somebody gets a
certain amount of cash or we raise a
certain amount for them we tell them
about the tax and stuff but yeah
sometimes it's crazy how that works but
yeah I gave away a car like last year it
wasn't even a fundraiser because it was
such a last second thing so I had to put
up on my own like I twenty thousand
dollars and I gave some them on this car
and then yeah we had to like pay the
taxes on it and stuff and so it's it's
crazy yeah there's like a gift tax even
when you give someone something you're
gonna you're gonna get a a price is
right situation where a lot of times is
Right were you actually yeah we'll get
to that in a second but when you when
you win the big well any prize in The
Price is Right you have to pay tax on
the fair market value of that item and
so if you win Jack like let's just say
some useless five thousand dollar thing
because half the stuff it's like you're
never gonna use these right if you win
that five that now you have to pay tax
on that five thousand dollars even
though it's an item that you'll never
use a lot of application yeah you'll
it's better just don't take it or
sometimes they have a cash value right
what happened when you you were on the
prices right yeah yeah would you carry
uh yeah it was yeah my uncle my uncle he
won the whole price is right I don't
know 15 years ago or something yeah
Parker he used my dad's ID because he
didn't think he was old enough to get in
yeah in the show but yeah he won the
whole thing and so he's like Jimmy go
down the Price Is Right I bet you could
get on and so like all right sounds good
like I'll show up and you you show up to
the prices right there's a line of like
a hundred people and they come up to you
and give you 15 seconds they say why
should you be on the show oh they'll pay
they'll pick you you have such a energy
to you yeah so it was funny my answer I
think was I was like
um well I was like well I sleep in my
Honda Accord I would sure love to have
another one and I'm a volunteer Santa
Claus and I pick up dog poop for a
living because I was in Austin Texas for
uh after I left the restaurant for
probably five months I was a full-time
dog walker and I walked around just
picked up dog poop took dogs on walks
and then I also always carried a Santa
Claus costume in my trunk of my Honda
because my one of my best friends he
said Jimmy you gotta learn to be Santa
Claus in private before you can be Santa
Claus in public and I took it literal
and I was like dang like yeah if any
time like I'll ever be known or I'll do
videos recording blessing you and stuff
like I just want to know that like I
wanna I wanna help way more people off
camera than on camera like that's the
goal you know know and so I would in
Texas after I get off work at the
restaurant I put on the Santa costume
just run around town hang out with
homeless people go to eat with strangers
buy people stuff and uh yeah I was like
a little Santa and it was it was hot
there it was hot you're living in your
car
um well at times I was when I would
drive cross country and stuff like you
know save enough money I would just
sleep in the car at a Walmart or
whatever but wow and that was that's
what was crazy really was about a year
and a half ago when I started doing
these tick tocks I was like man I know I
want to make videos and I just want to
do that full time and I want to just
help people all the time but I don't
have enough funds to just to do that for
every video you know I went like drain
my entire bank account like a year and a
half um taking just homeless people on
like parasail rides skydiving all this
stuff and eventually it's like dang it I
don't have any more phones to do this
what do I do and I went through
McDonald's drive-thru I didn't even have
two dollars for like a McChicken I had
to call my mom and she had to send me
money to buy it and I was like dang it
like I don't know what to do you know
and um and sure enough just I started
making these videos just and it started
growing and then I was like What if I
try fundraising I was like I wonder if
people would donate and so I pull up a
live stream I'm like all right guys I'm
gonna try to raise money to help someone
today and you know 100 came in I was
like all right that was cool tomorrow
it's not gonna happen they're not like
the person who just gave isn't going to
give another 100 and so I just win and
fundraising like 150 came in today and
it just kept growing I was like oh my
gosh like people really want want to
give a funds away and help people in
this country but they really want to see
a video or the face it goes to rather
than just write a check to organization
which is still great but a lot of people
they yeah they want to see the face of
someone and so when I realized I could
fundraise and do that I was like wow
this is incredible and now it's just a
dream come true every day I wake up go
on a little live stream raise funds hit
the street drive around my little Honda
and find awesome people and reward them
for their kindness and it's just it's a
blessing you didn't tell us about the
Price Is Right what happened to the
price yeah the price is right oh you get
on you get the guess the price yeah yeah
it was happened it was a bit interesting
yeah
um I was in the crowd and they said be
as crazy as you can they show the
highlights of The Price is Right you
know they say be as crazy as possible
like you can't go over the top well they
announced my name you know they say come
up on stage and I just start freaking
out going nuts I get on the state down
there and I'm just like the camera's
pacing I'm like doing like thumb tracks
and stuff and I'm like one power and all
this stuff stuff and uh they end up like
humming The Producers like you gotta
settle down like you're too anime
but didn't
it for you like I mean I was just loving
it was just nuts and uh yeah it was
crazy and then um and then yeah I got uh
I didn't get up on the stage but they
gave me like 500 for being on it
200 in taxes
so how much are you raising
today like like in an average day how
much would you expect to I don't want to
say make but a lot of it's raising to
give away yeah yeah yeah usually the
goal is whatever we raise that day we
usually go out and give it away so I'll
try to raise 500 sometimes a thousand
dollars and then just later that day
I'll go shoot the video and give away
that amount to the strangers and uh or
whoever it is and the people get to see
on Tick Tock later that day like wow I
donated three hours ago and here's the
video the guy I went to so it's really
cool how it's just uh yeah like the same
day they usually get to see the video of
who it wins have you given away money
today yet today we did not shoot a video
Vegas is crazy
um I was here yeah I don't know what
what I was doing today I was trying to
get a outfit ready for this show so I
was at Target I was going on this show
yes you don't need an outfit because
where's the Santa Claus thing I don't
care their clothes have been dirty for
like a week I'm like I don't know I I
got rid of all my clothes and I have
like five t-shirts to my name now and
I've just this shirt I've worn it like
three days in a row without washing it
and I was like I need something clean so
I went to Target bought a white T-shirt
but it was too thin it was really thin
and so I just said I'll just wear this
but yes different cities are different
so are you gonna give away money in
Vegas because I'd be concerned you give
away 500 bucks you'll see them just
immediately the craps yeah no I wouldn't
be doing it at a casino or nothing like
that but I did shoot a video here
yesterday actually where and uh at
Walmart and I just I don't know it's not
Christmas but I love Christmas and so I
just had like a a little microphone
thing and I went up to people I said
Rudolph the red nose and then went like
this and if they finish the lyrics to
the song they got the 500 and like five
people just stared at me like this
didn't say anything and then finally a
sweet old lady started singing the rest
of the song so she got the funds and and
yeah she I don't know how old she was
but she was awesome and we did a little
dance and she said she's gonna use it to
buy food so how are you making money to
to because it costs money to go to these
cities
um you know and you deserve something
too for all of your efforts and all of
your work too yeah I mean I honestly I
just yeah from my Amazon business
um that's one of the main ways that I
make funds and then I've just I'm just
really Frugal and like ever since I was
a kid when I was like 14 years old I've
just been investing every month whether
it was ten dollars a month or 300 a
month you know I've just always been
investing just compound interest I don't
have any debt my car's paid off all that
and so I can live pretty cheap you know
um but yeah uh mainly from Amazon and
then once in a while I'll do a brand
deal with like uh cash app or Lyft or
some of these awesome Brands and and
yeah it's just it's just amazing my goal
is just to yeah any funds that I make
from different things like it's just to
invest it to grow it because a lot of
the bigger dreams and Visions I have are
going to require a lot of funds to get
them done like yeah
um one of my main things that I really
want to do is
um a couple of years ago I was just in
my bedroom and I was sitting there I was
like man I was like why is church boring
I feel like church is kind of boring and
I was like I don't think Heaven is
boring and I was like I was like dang
what if church was like heaven and so I
was like I just had this idea for like a
host party Church like a wild that's
like this at this wild house where
there's like 500 to a thousand people
there
and you show up and um basically yeah we
give like a 10 minute message there's no
drugs no alcohol allowed but it's just
Community people having fun it's a 10
minute gospel message and then my dream
is just to be like um just uh yeah just
to like call people on the crowd and um
be like who doesn't have a car or who's
got car troubles raise your hand get up
here you just want a brand new model X
like and just uh yeah like pay off
people's college debt and all these
things and really just to love people
radically and she told people that God
is fun and holy at the same I think
people might hear about this though and
join for the wrong reasons maybe they
show up and it's like yo I heard about
this new uh this new ceremony you know
this you know Church yeah you need to
vet someone before yeah
definitely it's an idea you know that
definitely needs a team and some more
things around but the main concept is
just to yeah just just to have like a
fun atmosphere like heaven be blessing
people sure and um and yeah like yeah I
just have an offering bucket that goes
around where you don't even put in it
but people can just take out whatever
they need you know and just like have
the church run by businesses that are
self-funded and I don't know I just I
just want to like love people radically
and to show them that God is fun and
crazy and and yeah I have like a DJ
there and like guest speakers skydiving
in and just uh yeah I just want to be
fun and wild you know like I truly
believe that God is the originator and
he like creates everything you know and
the enemy he just comes and he just he
just changes
um things that God makes for good and
turns them to bad you know like I think
that like yeah if there's a college frat
party down the street and they're doing
drugs and it's wild and crazy I was like
man I was like I feel like heaven would
have a better party than that because
most of the people there are just sad
and depressed don't even want to be
there but are doing that so I just want
to make things fun and yeah just show
people like God's where did those
beliefs start for you is it as a kid
yeah I mean I've always you know gone to
church since I was a little kid you know
and stuff but yeah most most Sundays as
I was like kid I don't want to go to
church I just want to you know play
whatever video game Grand Theft Auto my
room or something like that you know
um but really when I was 18 years old
and uh yeah my socks got healed as crazy
as that is as wild that is
um that's kind of how I met Jesus and
yeah he's uh he's just changed my life
radically and and yeah I just that's why
I have so much hope for people's lives
you know because I truly don't believe
if someone's a mean person they're gonna
stay that way the rest of their life you
know I almost wanted to start like a
t-shirt brand called love mean people
like I think mean people are some of the
most people that just need the biggest
hug you know
um and yeah like I just I just yeah
Jesus is he changed my life and it's
just it's amazing you know do you ever
get any haters online not really yeah
not really I mean yeah I uh not too much
once in a while you get a hate comment
or something but I don't really care
about it like I said you know like when
I erased all my stuff you know and was
off the internet for four years I really
got my identity and that and not in the
videos and stuff and so yeah it doesn't
really affect me if there's a bad
comment this or that because there's
going to be that with anything you do
you know it's just you just have to make
sure your heart and your motives are
pure and then that's the rest is yeah
you know you're good so where are you
posting your videos YouTube Tick Tock
you're doing Facebook Instagram yeah is
it all the platforms Snapchat Facebook
YouTube just not Twitter because someone
has my old username and I don't want to
make like a random one with numbers or
something yeah but yeah YouTube's crazy
this this last Christmas I started
posting on there had like 10 subscribers
something like that now I have like 1.5
million yeah subscribers on them how
much do you make from YouTube YouTube
share that well these are all like uh
these are all short form videos yeah I'm
just curious because it is mostly shorts
yeah yeah so not really make a lot from
YouTube but uh eventually what we want
to do is start making long-form videos
on YouTube because there is great ad
Revenue in these things because I wanted
to start doing crazier giveaways you
know um I think you could do really well
especially Facebook making three to five
minute giveaway with interview yeah yeah
you know follow these people home right
and uh get them to share their story for
sure I remember they used to do it was
really popular like homeless people like
Transformations where they'd get
somebody and like try to clean them up
getting my hair cut maybe get them new
teeth or something like that and then
try to get him a job and just like you
know help them yeah that's a tough one
because on the one hand it's like it's a
nice gesture but on the other hand it's
like are they doing it just for the
views well it's it's I think I agree but
in Jimmy's case I feel like the views
just contributes to more money which
means helping more people which means
more money is yeah but no it's positive
but yeah to your point that's the key is
that's why we don't do that all the time
is because really the goal is if there's
a person that's on the street it's not
to just quick you make them look nice
get him a haircut make a video post it
see it goodbye it's like we build
relationships with these people so
there's a homeless lady right now that
I've been helping trying to get her off
the street for the past like uh five
months and um and yeah we're in the
process of it right now just getting our
new teeth
um yeah getting her a job and all these
different things and yeah it takes a
long time you don't just pump something
out like that because you're dealing
with actual people
um you know but like Norma she's she's
amazing this this lady Norma how do you
guys meet oh me and me and my girlfriend
yeah so I uh I've never had a girlfriend
my whole life just yeah I just never
wanted to ask someone to be my
girlfriend unless I really saw great
values in them and just really connected
with them you know and so I um this it
was a couple months ago I went to Kansas
City to this event it's like a Christian
Stadium event and I went there to speak
at one of the pre-rally things for it
and before I went up to speak I saw this
girl in the crowd I was like dang that's
a beautiful girl she looks amazing and I
go up there and speak and get off the
stage come down and then I ran into her
out in the area we started talking and
she was from Palm Springs which is like
my favorite place on Earth and uh yeah
we we started hanging out that night and
um yeah like five days later something I
asked her to be my girlfriend it was
really quick it was really fast but
she's awesome she said yes yeah well she
said no but uh here she is yeah she
helps me with videos and stuff like that
and she just has awesome pure heart and
so so is she the one now behind the
camera sometimes or do you have someone
else too well it's just me usually it's
just me I I feel like that's right
hidden camera style yeah yeah but um but
yeah definitely it helps when there's
someone out there with me driving around
finding people looking for the right
person what was interesting to me is you
said when you were like in that stage of
kind of sleeping in your car like the
before the price price is right and
stuff like that uh when you had no money
you were still giving away like a lot of
what you could to random people like you
mentioned taking people like paragliding
and stuff like yeah yeah uh how did you
like reason that financially in order to
like to do that yeah I mean honestly I
just always knew that like just from uh
just from Biblical principles and
reading the Bible just like you know the
goals just never to really live for
myself but just to help other people out
and do that and so yeah ever since I was
a kid like as soon as I have five
thousand dollars in my bank account I'd
like give get rid of it the next day or
week and just give it to people help
people out and yeah a couple years ago
there was a very large amount it was
like I don't know I think it was like
half of my entire net worth and I felt
like God said to give it away and I was
like what like are you sure like my dad
would say it's a horrible decision or it
just doesn't make sense financially you
know especially when you get older you
know and you're living on your own and
stuff but I ended up doing that anyways
gave away that money and as soon as I
did that that's when my Amazon business
like took off it was crazy who'd you
give it to
um I gave it to this guy he was from my
town he was like
um they just I don't know they they go
around helping people and stuff him and
his wife they're just awesome people
have been family friends with them
forever and I gave him the funds and I
actually ran into them
um uh like a couple months ago and this
was a long time ago this was maybe four
years ago I gave him the money and they
say they still have the money they still
have part of it because they give it
away and someone else would randomly
would give it to them they put it in the
same envelope so the envelopes never run
dry and one of my favorite Dawn people
that donate to my videos he always says
no one goes broke by giving you know and
so it's kind of that thing where yeah
like when you're when your hand is like
this like to your money and you're
greedy and you're holding it like God
can't bless you with more but when
you're giving to people he can also
bless you the more because he knows it's
not an idol in your life and you're not
going to yeah just like it's not gonna
rule you you know so I just I love
giving and um it's just really an
awesome part of life just to see people
transform like I was just telling
someone this other day like I can't
remember Maybe three maybe two times in
my entire life where a random stranger
blessed me with something that's crazy
right
um one one instance I was in North
Dakota getting a haircut and uh this day
I was gonna pay for the haircut and they
go yeah the old man back there paid for
your haircut it's like twenty dollar
haircut I was like you're kidding me
what and I literally got in my car
called like 50 people I knew I was like
guys you won't believe this some guy
bought my haircut because it's just it
hits you when someone random pays for
something and I was like wow like it
doesn't need to be 500 or a thousand
dollars like if you just get someone a
coffee like you can make their day maybe
even their month and really impact them
like that you know it's neat I have one
more question too
um is that Lexar Alex what yeah yeah
don't don't but don't look at the sign
back here guys I thought it was going to
be about uh Lexar the memory no no no no
no no it's a legitimate question here so
I've seen studies that um people are
more inclined to be nice to you if
you're good looking and Jimmy NE let's
not lie here look oh you're such a good
looking man but uh do you think that
your your looks have affected the way
that people pass the kindness to us yeah
I don't know that's a tricky question
that's a good question Alex that's a
good question I guess at the end of the
day I would not really know you know but
I would say that I don't know I have a I
have a bit of a strange voice you know
like honestly you know where my voice
comes from like my daddy is like forcing
me he owns a restaurant he forced me to
like be a waiter when I was younger I
was so terrified to do it and when I
became a waiter like you come up to
these tables and in my town where I was
a waiter everyone who comes in there
like they're a bit older most of them
they're like 70 80 year old people and
you don't want to startle them you know
so you come up and you go hey hello sir
would you like anything besides water
and you get this like high-pitched voice
you know and I guess it's kind of stuck
with me that like I have this voice with
this Minnesota accent so I think it is a
bit disarming and when I come up to
people it is a bit disarming you know
like I don't come up to me and say hey
could you give me you know some money
for Brett you know it's like that's true
you know you kind of I kind of greet
them in a way but I I wouldn't say that
yeah they just help me because they
think I'm a good looking kid or I'm nice
you know because yeah when you talk to
these people they've been helping people
their entire lives in just that one
moment they were captured and it was on
film thing is you look kind of like your
beard just got you know clean shaven
around it you look like you got a fresh
haircut right you know sometimes yeah a
lot of times I wear a mask sure you know
because yeah a lot of people will come
up and recognize me and yeah like if
Jack did that people run
oh yeah one little bit one crazy thing I
guess I haven't brought up quite yet was
um basically yeah uh it was about four
years ago I was in Northern California
at this Christian school and I wasn't
making videos I wasn't doing anything
online it's when I had fully given it to
God and I was there at this church and a
lady randomly comes up to me and she
goes I have a word so like I have a
prophecy I feel like God's speaking to
me about you and I was like all right
what is it and she goes yeah in the next
four years you're gonna have your own TV
show and all these things she starts
saying and I'm like what the heck like
all right that sounds fun but what like
what are you crazy like that's a TV show
like how do you even get a TV show you
know and it was just crazy and I wasn't
doing videos or anything and fast
forward
um it's been about four years now like
three and a half years and I'm actually
yeah like I I'm working with uh Jason
Kennedy and Taylor Lautner and we're
actually having meetings this week or or
next week with different networks like
pitching a TV show and stuff and it
looks like it's probably gonna happen so
it's just very crazy what can happen
like when you speak life into somebody
you know and you encourage them and yeah
I truly feel like yeah like I'm only
making videos and doing this because I
feel like it's what God called me to it
just feels like you know like when you
throw a football it just throws right
but you dribble football it's all over
the place you know and I feel like I'm
doing what I was designed to do which is
just to meet awesome people share their
stories and just inspire people to be
kind and do that like about 30 minutes
ago I was at Target before I came here
and this lady she's like Jimmy from
YouTube It's funny she's at YouTube
because I'm a YouTuber but apparently
you know I'm growing on there too and
she's like I want a picture this this
and she goes me and my daughter watch
your videos and now we try to buy people
stuff behind behind us and this and that
and that's really the best thing
compliment I could ever get is like
they're inspired to be kind
and to realize it doesn't have to be
some crazy thing like literally if you
just open the door for somebody
especially in Las Vegas like they'll be
shocked they'll be like what you're
opening the door for me you know and you
can just a little thing of kindness can
really impact people and do you have any
selfish desires like do you want to have
a fancy car or like really nice clothes
or to live in a nice apartment or going
you know lavish fancy vacations I mean
basically yeah I I like uh this shirt
it's actually it's my merch that I
launched this is like one one shirt that
I have but I have uh like five black
t-shirts and five white t-shirts that's
all I like for clothes I don't like
anything crazy my car I love my Honda
because I can go to a different rougher
areas and it's not like it doesn't stick
out like oh let's Rob this kid or
something you know so I just like
everything plain and simple like that
um but as far as like selfish desires I
guess I love doing fun wild things like
to go on a wild vacation or this but
with other people you know whether it be
with my family or taking somebody on a
trip you know it's really just uh yeah
it's fun doing stuff with other people
you know but yeah I'm not really into
like watches or cars or nothing like
that you know like I just like a nice
you know just I'm very clean I I don't
know if I have OCD maybe you know but my
apartment is just very clean organized
and yeah I just like things very simple
yeah what about travel
want to travel anywhere yeah I mean I
traveled a lot I love traveling uh right
when I got out of high school uh yeah I
lived in uh India for a while I lived in
Australia and I lived in Brazil
um so I traveled around there and that's
really kind of how a lot of My Views
were shaped is just seeing different
people and cultures and places and
that's why I feel like I'm able to go up
to anyone and connect with them right
away and um yeah just like seeing people
in those other countries man they're so
nice it's crazy like in India like you
could just walk down the street meet
somebody and they'll like invite you to
live with them for like a couple weeks
it's insane and that was a really that
that time in India really shaped my life
a lot what are the least friendly
countries that you've been to oh
oh yeah I don't know about that I mean
everywhere you know you'll run into
different people like depending on the
city wherever
um but yeah honestly I just think that
I just think that yeah people if they're
if they're if they're rude it's because
something happened to them that day or
that week you know so I just I don't try
to like condemn or put a label on anyone
you know because I think identity is one
of the main things and if I right now
set a certain country or a place like I
don't want someone to be watching it and
to be like wow this is I'm from a mean
place all right like that's who I am
that's who we are like no you might have
a couple mean people in your town but
like that's not who you are you know
when's the last time you got like uh you
know Road Rage or something like that
where maybe like because it happens to
the best of us right we're like we act
out of line and then we reflect back on
that maybe like later that day a day or
two later and we're like I shouldn't
have said what I said or done when I did
right oh my gosh because for me it's
just like this is what bewilders me I
could never picture you doing anything
yeah in that capacity no I mean uh I
mean I'm definitely not perfect you know
there's no such thing as a perfect
person you know so I would never claim
to be absolutely perfect but I would say
if I ever her was driving and was like
you know got mad or this or that like
just kind of later that night like my
key is just every day try to connect
with God just Olivia that night or in
the morning just be with Jesus and if I
find selfishness in me or if I was rude
or this or that just kind of just repent
of it right then and there and just
receive his forgiveness and just kind of
move forward you know the word
repentance everyone's scared of it but
it's actually it doesn't mean really
what you think it means what it means is
like to have a different perspective
from like a penthouse view like looking
down at something like you're going this
way decide to go this way it's not like
oh I'm so sorry blah blah blah like you
don't need to cry to repent you know
it's really just to realize wow I'm I
that's not who I am I can do better than
that and you just kind of move on from
it and so just kind of live a lifestyle
like that man but uh there's always
things that pop up you know there's
always different things where you're
like man I uh maybe was a little selfish
I didn't ask my girlfriend where she
wanted to eat I just chose where to eat
or this or that you know but really at
the end of the day it's yeah just
connecting with him and and yeah and
when you go and you tip at restaurants
do you tip like pretty you know yeah
yeah yeah do you just tip normally yeah
yeah no I I I I tip pretty good because
I used to be a server you know so I
remember sometimes I'd get a hundred
dollar tip and it my head would fall off
of my body like I would just blow me
apart and so yeah when we go out to eat
like try to tip pretty good you know and
bless people up but um but yeah it seems
like every day why the cool thing about
Tick Tock is I don't do a video once a
week usually every day we do a video so
every day we usually get a bless
somebody in a cool radical way but what
we like doing more like when I'm on my
own instead of just giving someone a
crazy tip is give them an awesome tip
but then just talk to them get to know
him pray for them and um yeah just
that's like a really cool way to impact
someone versus just giving them money so
what's your schedule like now like walk
us through an average day yeah an
average day wake up
um yeah just eat some cereal
and uh basically yeah turn on my live
stream and uh I just yeah raised 500 to
a thousand dollars and then I go and uh
get the money out of the ATM and then I
drive around sometimes for hours find
the person bless them hear their story
and then go edit the video after that uh
work out hang out with God for a little
bit you know just read the Bible and um
just kind of repeat do the same thing
but it's a it's a blast you know it's
like it'd be one thing if it was uh if
it was really uh sad or difficult thing
but just hanging out with people having
fun with them blessing them it's like
it's like the funnest thing on the
planet how much strategy though goes
into let's say getting the right shot
the Right video the right person uh that
you know would do well online so the key
is you know it can be tempting sometimes
to think like this you know and it'd be
like all right we need the best shot
this and that but the key when I make my
best videos is when I kind of forget
about all that and kind of get the heart
of the video because that's really what
you can feel like you can feel a video
like some people will either try to copy
my videos this that and sometimes
they're amazing sometimes they're great
but you can tell if someone just does it
for the views or this or that like
there's no real Connection in the video
there's no real heart in it you know so
the key is to kind of forget that and
just kind of go out and just try to make
someone's day you know make them feel
loved and the camera will capture all
that and then you can edit it later but
it's really yeah to find the heart of
the video and not to get too caught up
in algorithms and this and that because
you know that's really that's like the
best thing and I know like you guys have
probably learned this and even on
YouTube people really love that that uh
style that's not so crazy edited and
it's more just raw and stuff like people
like to just see things and not feel
like it's a big huge production you know
that's what I kind of feel like we're
going in that direction and I think Ryan
Trahan was really good push for that
movement of just anti-editing no big
production not spending a lot of money
something simple people could follow it
and it helps Ryan Trahan is really
really funny too yeah but I love those I
I'm a huge fan of them but it has to be
well articulated there has to be like
some sort of editing and stuff thrown in
there I don't think it has to be this
big optimized thing yeah yeah absolutely
what was it uh we we all watch I love
his content uh what's his name Hiller
Smith oh yeah Nate Miller Smith uh his
editing is insane yeah his editing looks
like a movie like you're watching a
Michael Bay film and watching him go
through
um Matthew beams video was insane are
you roasting it yeah so he goes through
this video is like you could optimized
here you could cut this out you could
change the music I mean watch it because
it blows your mind in terms of how much
thought yeah well I guess second yeah I
guess I will say this like for example
my video I did yesterday where it was
first person to finish the lyrics to a
Christmas song got 500 I um I I was
gonna read a comment for that video and
say first person and give 500 and then
the video would start because that way
it gives context otherwise if you're
just a new person watching and you just
see me like going like this you don't
know someone's gonna get blessed you
don't know anything and you'll click off
and so I actually had I posted that
video
um with no comment reading because Tick
Tock sometimes like bans certain words
like Rudolph the red nose reindeer
wouldn't be allowed to be typed on Tick
Tock so I had to remove the comment
actually yeah yeah I don't know it's
just could it be like this yeah it's
really something it's really strange so
anyways I posted the video yesterday
um without the comment reading just
straight into the video and it did
horrible it was like one of the worst
performing videos ever I was like dang
it it's because there's no context
people don't know what's going on so I
deleted the video re-put it up with me
reading the comment and did really well
and so yeah it's just making sure people
have context and understand what's going
on in the video and then two one of my
main things to do is I love at the end
of my videos dancing with people
um I try to end it with like Joy so even
if it's emotional this and that it's a
joyful thing they're getting funds they
got blessed they were kind so we try to
dance for four or five seconds at the
end of each video and the the followers
love it they think it's amazing they
come out we love the dancing but
whenever I do it the views are way less
on the video because people read it then
they see the video and they scroll off
and so
um it's kind of just navigating do you
want to make the video for new people to
come and follow and to see it or just to
really show the people that have stuck
around for a long time just to give them
like a deeper connection so I'll do a
lot of that sometimes where it's like
forget about if it performs way less
like people love the dancing you know
should we react to a few of the videos
it might be interesting what do you
think Jack sure let's watch these top
three that you've pinned okay all right
yeah tell us maybe give us some of the
backstory or if you want to comment on
the video might be kind of interesting
give us some like behind the scenes or
like anything that the viewer might not
know hello sir how you doing could I
could I uh would you like face paint no
okay could I paint your face like a
design right there pause it right there
so yeah this video I shot this video I
get home to my apartment I'm editing it
I post it and then I always show my
roommates at the end of the day like the
video I did so I'm showing my roommates
I'm like check this out and my one
roommate right when he gets this part
just starts screaming freaking out
running around the apartment I'm like
what he's like bro do you know who that
is I was like no she's like that's my
stepdad yeah yeah and he's like this
televangelist like uh I don't know like
he's like really famous in other
countries like this guy and uh I was
like oh no should I delete it like I
hope it doesn't make him look rude but
he was funny and laughed with it but it
was just super random like I went up to
my roommate's stepdad in Walmart where'd
you get the idea to ask to paint
people's faces
um well uh I don't know just just
sir please it'll make my whole year if
you regret it I'll give you a new car if
you said that I would I would do it you
don't need a new car part but just like
it'll make my year I'm like you know
what right right yeah yeah yeah like a
design for free okay hello sir would you
like a free face painting you could do a
design you could even wipe it off after
okay you're amazing you know that so who
is this how do you find this guy I was
just driving around in my car and uh saw
him like sitting outside of this ice
cream place or whatever and I was like
well let's go up to him and uh he was it
was actually really special because he
was very monotoned very down and out
like hello and by the end of the video
like you'll see it he's like laughing
having fun and that's why I went so
viral like people could see that you
know he wasn't sometimes if you're
shooting a video you're like all right I
want to find someone joyful to go up to
but sometimes it's like man let's find
someone who's really down and out and
see if you can switch that 500 for me
yes I was seeing the first person child
like enough I don't think I can check
500 so you know that's legit when
they're like I can't take it
that's when you know that like oh yeah
no we've got to give them the money
they're the ones that deserve it yeah so
this will help you get out of here
really actually yeah everyone needs to
not take themselves so serious
I love that that is a great ending yeah
yeah yeah it's it's uh not surprising
why this did so well right it's uh yeah
let's watch the next one look at this
one uh 40 million views
I was just trying to get a sad meal I'll
do it for you
why'd he come up to you I it was a very
interesting situation I was at this
Walmart the McDonald's in the Walmart
and I stood there for like 20 30 minutes
I didn't even know if I was gonna make a
video or not I was just I was like I'm
trying to think of something and people
kept saying do you want to order do you
want to order I was like no I'm good and
I was like and then he came up to me I
was like oh this is perfect like yeah I
can't afford the McDonald's how does he
not see you record the the whole
interaction yeah I mean it's a it's a
hidden camera and uh yeah I don't ever
reveal exactly how I do it just because
I don't want people to figure it out or
know how I do it and like come up to me
or see my kind of setup sure but yeah I
mean you can just kind of tell in
people's faces and stuff that they're
unaware of so they thought that maybe
you were standing there didn't have the
money or maybe you were just falling on
Hard Times want to help you out yeah
yeah because they kept saying you want
to order something I'm like no I'm good
I don't really have much and and um yeah
then he came out
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah I mean I don't know yeah she
gave his number I didn't give him the
money there because uh like you're not
allowed to take money sometimes where
they're working oh did you ask to give
him the money and he said he couldn't no
just from previous videos
tip employees which kind of sucks but
yeah I was like I'll wait till after
this guy gets out of work yeah
give you this gift again thank you this
is for you this is a thousand dollars
yes I do undercover kindness you're
amazing I like his shirt why isn't no
one commenting on this oh all the
comments are both yeah
absolutely
even if I don't have my words
video and he got like uh 10 15 000 came
in oh yeah yeah yeah crazy that's what's
so wild it's like I'm kind of just doing
the little that I can and and that I can
raise but then it's really just giving
this video to the internet and then they
take it next time gosh my first ever
like viral video on Tick Tock uh I was
actually on a road trip in California
with my friends and uh he was just
freaking out and stuff and I don't know
he was it was he was having a rough day
and just he made the road trip it was it
was a rough road trip like I don't know
he he didn't have some of his medication
and stuff and was just angry all the
time and this that so I was in Northern
California and I was actually sad
because because of how what he was going
through and stuff so I literally I was
like I'm gonna make a video I'm gonna go
to McDonald's right now and order a sad
meal because I am sad and I ordered a
sad meal at McDonald's and uh that video
got like nine million views wow that's
what started
do you have any other questions for us
anything we could answer for you yeah
any questions for you guys is um yeah I
don't know man I think it's just awesome
that you guys got a podcast I was
thinking the other day is like I'd love
to do a podcast I feel like it's just so
hard though to know like questions to
ask now you could do podcasts with some
of the people that you feature on Tick
Tock yeah uh not you know the the
podcast soft white underbelly just like
that the exact same thing but with a
positive spin because I watch a lot of
those videos and there's not a lot of it
it's you hear these really interesting
stories and you hear their perspective
but I feel like yours is very uplifting
yeah and you feel better afterwards so
sometimes the software underbelly I'm
left like oh man like what did I just do
yeah yeah crazy stuff yeah so if you did
something like that just 20 minutes
right I wouldn't do an hour right 20
minutes edit it up maybe 30 minutes max
just get their back these babies right
here yeah and bless them at the end or
you know if you enjoy the story
you want to reach out to them uh you
want to help in some way something like
that would be really nice for sure don't
worry about the questions they'll do
most of this I feel like your audience
could get really attached to some of the
people you help out and I'm sure that
they would want to hear their entire
story like to us it's very interesting
how people get in certain situations
yeah it would be fun I love it I love it
that's your next thing yeah oh baby all
right I'm coming out with one there you
go please please do
um and just uh make sure that they hit
the like button yeah that's right oh
preferably get a free stock Down Below
in the description what else I mean is
there anything else you wanted to
discuss any exciting things yeah I think
just uh yeah the main thing is just
um yeah I'm just I'm excited to see if
this TV show thing happens you know that
will be crazy because we'll be able to
help you on a whole different scale like
give away houses and all this stuff like
that will just be insane and so fun to
do
um and partner up with celebrities doing
it is kind of the vision and the goal
but
um I'm excited to do that and then yeah
I guess any other stories really or
anything
um
yeah I think I think the main thing is
just I couldn't do any of this without
the people that donate to the videos and
just really you have to for anyone out
there that wants to do something similar
to this you got to start small whether
it be buying someone's coffee or ten
dollars twenty dollars and once you
build trust with the audience then you
can kind of be able to raise money and
then be able to go give that away to
people because they're not just going to
donate if they don't know you or don't
trust you or see you giving away your
own money you know yeah um so so that's
a key for anyone out there watching and
I would just say yeah there's different
ways to be kind that you can really
impact somebody's life and um and yeah
it's uh it's just it's amazing what what
you can do to somebody by just spending
the time talking to them and helping
them out and I'm just so grateful to be
able to get to do this and I just love
it I can't wait to find the next person
on the street you know because right now
there's somebody out there that they
just had bad luck they just had a couple
bad things happen to them and they're
out there and they just need someone to
believe in them I guess the other thing
I was just gonna say is I'm excited as
far as YouTube goes because I've been
trying to find a form about for longer
form videos instead of just hidden
cameras or that like we created a place
on my website where you can fill out
your story a three minute video
submission and then we kind of go
through these and just we'll be able to
pick stories and go have permission to
film go and do these videos where yeah
we get to change their life through
crowdfunding and stuff and to follow up
I think your YouTube channel 20 30
minute follow-ups yeah interviews the
people you help because that way
everyone that sees your your tick tocks
they want they want to know the full
story like I'd be curious on that guy
right I go to the channel and watch a 20
minute interview yeah it would be cool
to see it behind the scenes too I know
you said you didn't want to like reveal
how you film or whatever you have going
on there but it'd be cool like like a
waking up a day in the life of Jimmy
darts or something or someone films you
filming the thing and it's like behind
the scenes that would ruin the magic I
think there's something magical about
not knowing really yeah the magic yeah
yeah honestly I think the mystery is is
of how we filmed like of what it's like
to give money to people yeah I think
it's it's simpler for people to see the
45 seconds and well he'd release that
first until now but I think it would be
funny also to see your face when you're
giving away money my face yeah like a
b-real thing yeah it's like you're
showing you're like oh yeah
yeah yeah that would be cool too that'd
be awesome well thanks thanks appreciate
it let me get a thumbnail of you all
right perfect